There was a gentleman,
I just covered him on my,
on my youtube channel.
Oh,
I don't know who he is.
His name is,
I think Noah Carl.
He's a young,
I think postdoc at Cambridge University who from all I know is a very reasonable
gentlemen who had been invited to speak at a conference on intelligence.
And because of that,
a bunch of folks decided to put together an open letter arguing that Cambridge
University should not hire this guy.
And so on.
This is now become the,
the standard way by which the baits are our resolve.
You,
you signed these open letters,
so for had another guy on and you should definitely check this,
this guy out.
His name is Alessandra Stromeyer.
Uh,
he is a physicist.
Do you know this case?
No.
He's a physicist at the University of Pisa who is also a,
who was a research scientist at cern,
the,
the nuclear research center in Geneva.
Uh,
he was invited to speak at a gender and theoretical physics conference.
Everything's about identity politics.
And of course the narrative was going to be,
you know,
women are discriminated against in physics and you know,
we need to help them,
you know,
improve their lot and physics and so on.
So he got up and he presented Biblio metric data.
So let me just for your viewers,
explain what that is.
The real metric data is,
is uh,
data that quantifies science.
So for example,
if I want to know,
uh,
which disciplines sites,
which other discipline,
I will look at citation patterns across disciplines.
Does economics ever site physics?
That's physics ever sites,
uh,
economics,
right?
So bibliometric data is a way to parameterize science.
And so what he did is he looked at for a given job in physics,
if a woman gets a job versus a Furman gets a job,
how many citations did they have?
Citation is basically how many other people have cited your work when you
published it.
So you and I might have had,
have published 50 papers each,
but you've been cited 10,000 times.
I haven't cited 2000 times.
Therefore,
your work is more influential,
even though we've both published the same amount of papers.
And he showed through very objective data that for a given position,
women were getting the jobs at much lower citations while that was construed as
terribly offensive,
terribly sexist,
you know,
Nazi like and so over 1600 scientists using the,
the appellation particles for justice.
I'm not making this up.
What you can go to articles for just young Jamie can check it out yet and you
can,
you can read their letter and it includes I think one or two of your former
guests who,
um,
have become a very anti fan of anti fan and not antifa.
Uh,
uh,
because to me they're,
they're sounding like intellectual cowers and fools.
Who were these people?
Uh,
I think one of them is Sean Carroll.
you know who that is?
I think he's feeling shore's been on several times.
Yeah.
So he's on that list and I don't know,
I don't want to misspeak,
but I think maybe Neil degrasse Tyson is on it,
but maybe not.
So that one,
that one I'll,
I'll,
I'll hold off on that one.
But definitely Sean Carroll is on it because I've even tagged him and I said,
hey,
come on my show.
That's discuss it.
So the letter was basically,
it starts off and it says,
we will not tolerate that.
Someone within our community,
I'm,
I'm paraphrasing,
will question the humanity of anyone based on their race,
their gender,
their gender orientation.
He didn't no such thing.
All he did was report bibliometric data to either support the contention that
women in physics were being discriminated against or not,
that should not yield a,
an open letter that chastises him and the way that they did,
not the only thing that he did incorrectly in my view.
And he's admitted to it.
He came on my show recently.
At one point during the presentation,
he showed his bibliometric profile versus two other women that had gotten a job
over him.
So he personalized it and,
and,
and doing that,
some people thought that that was inappropriate and that's fair.
Maybe it's not a nice thing to do to present,
you know,
your CV versus someone else and a public conference.
Maybe we can discuss that.
But the idea that we can't use bibliometrics objective scientific data to either
prove or disprove a narrative is insane,
and yet 1600 people decided to sign that letter.
That does seem ridiculous,
especially when it's an accusatory narrative.
You're accusing people of sexual discrimination and then the scientific data
shows otherwise exactly what they're looking for,
a quality of outcome,
right?
They're looking for an equal amount of female physicist and sal amount.
That's you just,
you're not going to get an equal amount of people interested in it.
So then you,
what you really have to shows,
you have to determine that there's been something that's holding those people
back from achieving that goal.
Is there some sort of a concerted effort to keep women out of that field?
That's what should be demonstrated and when you demonstrate that,
I think here's the,
here's the glass half full version of that.
You're looking at that,
the blue bibliometric data.
What that shows is that people are encouraging women to get into this because
it's the opposite,
right?
That instead of them being held back,
they're actually,
they're,
they're looking to even out the playing field and help these women along.
The problem with that is then it makes it look like the women aren't as capable
as the mat,
so not as effective as the men with their work and you know,
that's bad for everybody.
That's bad for women and for men.
It's bad for science because it makes it look like you're not being objective,
which is what all we want.
Every everyone who's not a scientist like myself.
What I want more than anything is to know that you're,
if you're a scientist,
I want to know that what you're telling me is a fact.
What I don't want is your own political spin on that fact because you don't want
to be criticized at work by radical feminists are radical leftist or any people
that might in some way potentially misconstrue your actions and your thoughts as
being sexist or what,
or fill in the blank,
homophobic,
transphobic,
whatever,
whatever the fuck it is that you're scared of.
I don't want to hear that.
What I want to hear is that you're looking at reality.
There are brilliant women out there,
there's brilliant men out there,
and a lot of those brilliant women choose not to do the same fields is brilliant
men.
And as long as no one's holding them back,
that shouldn't be a problem to problem is got to be in someone being held back,
someone discriminating,
someone trying to keep you out.
And you Kinda have to demonstrate that.
And I'm sure that exists.
I'm sure that exists.
I'm sure there's women out there that are hearing this right now that have
experienced all sorts of discrimination,
sexual discrimination,
sexual harassment,
and they have their own personal stories.
This is true,
but that not is not necessarily why the data reflects that.
There's more men that are successful at this.
It could seriously,
this is,
this is what people are really uncomfortable with.
Seriously represented.
There's differences in the sexist.